all they had to do was give the babylon
b its account back
all the libs had to do
was just not censor every little tiny
thing that they disliked all the way
down to a satire website but they
couldn't do it
the libs who ran twitter just couldn't
do it
so elon musk had to take twitter away
from them
it is now official the company has
confirmed that elon musk is the owner of
twitter
it all went down exactly as he said it
would
in less than three weeks elon musk went
from announcing a major investment in
twitter to gobbling up the entire
company to take it private
at first the board tried to stop the
takeover by offering musk a board seat
that didn't work
then they tried to stop the takeover by
issuing a poison pill to water down his
shares and stop him from buying more
that didn't work then they leaned on
woke financial institutions blackrock
state street to block the takeover
that didn't work the kingdom of saudi
arabia even got in on the action trying
to stop musk from buying twitter
that didn't work
in the end elon musk bought twitter for
exactly the price that he offered from
the very start he got
exactly what he wanted and he didn't pay
one penny more than he offered
the move is
terrific for a lot of reasons for one
the libs are losing their minds they
have not cried this hard since election
night 2016 which is
delightful
also important censored conservatives
will likely get their voice back on
twitter
which is important because twitter is in
many ways the public square and speaking
in the public square is how republics
govern themselves a lot of conservatives
are reporting right now that their
follower accounts have exploded
overnight their engagement has exploded
overnight i've seen it myself i'm up
something like 25 000 followers in 24
hours
part of that might be the fire tweets
that i'm sending but i think maybe a
clearer explanation is technologically
algorithmically
something must have changed no less
important though than than both of those
reasons perhaps the most delightful part
of it all
elon musk is right now in real time
vindicating the great man theory of
history the idea that individual men can
actually shift to some degree
and set and reset the course of human
events
for years now the libs have wanted us to
believe that individuals cannot make a
difference that history is governed
simply merely by an impersonal science
quote unquote that that will unfold
regardless of what human beings actually
want or do
the arc of history inevitably bending
toward whatever the libs want
they were so confident
and then in walks some eccentric south
african billionaire possibly a
conservative i'm not even really sure
to take not only twitter but their total
absolute hegemony and their confidence
away from them absolutely
love it i'm michael knowles that's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from roy munson who
says
i'm shocked at how long it took for this
insanity to be a major story marjorie
taylor green has bigger cajones than
most of those rhinos in office and no
one has spoken up about this kangaroo
court bs good point this is on how the
the georgia democrats are dragging
marjorie greene this republican
congressman to court
using a
little-known provision of the 14th
amendment to try to stop her from being
on the ballot
because they know they can't beat her at
the ballot they know she's very popular
so if they want to beat the republicans
they've got to stop
marjorie greene from ever even appearing
there
it's it's probably not going to work
though okay because we the people are
are taking back to to at least some
degree our government we're doing things
for ourselves when you want to fix your
car by yourself you got to check out
rock auto right now go to rockauto.com
enter knowles in there how did you hear
about his box
it seems these days like every store
wants to sell every single thing even
the things that they don't know anything
about
that's not rock auto rock auto is the
expert in auto parts they have been
doing this online for 20 years it's a
family business they know what they are
doing so when you want
parts for your car or truck where do you
go you go to rockauto.com they always
have the lowest prices there's no
gimmicks there's no login at 2 am and
get 15 off no there's no you've got to
be a professional to get this special
price versus the regular retail shopper
no it's the same price for pros and
do-it-yourselfers the catalog is so easy
to navigate even i can do it it's very
simple your life is complicated enough
when you need a part for your car or
truck go to the experts rockauto.com get
the brakes shocks carpet wipers
headlights mirrors mufflers lug nuts or
any other parts that you need and be
sure to enter knowles in their how did
you hear about spocs so they know that
we sent you
the libs have 180 degrees pivoted from
their previous argument on twitter
the previous argument was that this is
horrible if elon musk takes over twitter
it will be the end of the world
he's actually offering a low
a low offer for the company 54.20 per
share that's low twitter actually has
more value than that the board's got to
stop him the shareholders have to stop
him blackrock state street saudi arabia
they've all got to stop elon musk and
and then
he got it
through a number of maneuvers elon musk
got what he wanted and now the libs are
trying through their tears they're
trying to plaster on a smile and say oh
no this is fine no this is good actually
ha actually elon musk is an idiot
he paid a lot of money for twitter ha ha
the joke's on him the twitter
shareholders they're the ones who just
made
44 billion dollars ha ha what an idiot
he got ripped off
this uh argument does not really work
because they were making the opposite
argument just a few days ago
but let's even go with it one
elon musk offered 54 20 cents per share
and that's what he got that is a
considerable premium over a 30 premium
on what he
on what the value of the stock was when
he announced that he owned nine percent
of the company and it's a 50 premium or
more over the price of the stock when
elon musk first actually
started buying twitter
so yes he did he did pay a little bit
more money
but if it's such a good deal
for twitter if this is such a bad deal
for elon musk
why didn't the twitter leadership take
the deal when he first offered it
why did twitter and the leadership and
the institutional investors
fight the deal tooth and nail if it's
such a good deal if 54 bucks and 20
cents per share is such a good deal why
didn't they jump at the opportunity to
have it
because it's obviously not a good deal
for twitter it might be if you just look
at the numbers
but twitter is about more than just the
numbers elon musk said it he said this
is not primarily an economic decision
for me
and that's not just
a political
twist of rhetoric
it's
it's important because the value of
twitter is not merely in the dollars and
cents and the ability to advertise and
monetize the value of twitter is
controlling the public square
twitter is the smallest of the big tech
companies
facebook is much bigger google is much
bigger but twitter does punch above its
weight because so many blue checks so
many influence peddlers so many so many
opinion makers are on twitter and so if
you control
twitter you are controlling a huge
portion of the digital public square if
you control the public square you
control the government you control the
political order
and so
this doesn't totally solve the problem
because we now we just have our
billionaire controls it which is
something that's a start it's better
than their billionaires controlling it's
better than their corrupt institutions
controlling it
but
that that's the value in twitter sure
it's a little bit the advertising share
it's a little bit the monetization but
much more than that if you can control
the way that discourse happens in
america
which is at least a name of
self-government at least at least in
theory the way we govern ourselves as we
persuade one another then you have an
insane amount of power why do you think
saudi arabia cares
saudi arabia's got enough money if they
want to make money they can just put a
straw in the ground and pump oil out of
it why do you think saudi arabia was
throwing its weight around on twitter
why do you think huge institutional
actors were throwing their weight around
on twitter
it's not because it's the biggest
company in the world it's because it
plays a huge role in controlling speech
in america and now we've got at least
us a shift
in that power away from the libs which
had hegemonic control over it towards
something more closely resembling the
tradition of free speech in america so
that's the first cope that the democrats
and the libs have well who he overpaid
ha ha this is actually good for us okay
sure sure why were you fighting it so
hard then brian stelter on cnn has a
different cup which is
okay so elon musk got twitter even
though we fought him tooth and nail on
it well
who's even going to use twitter anymore
i i think that's a that's a that's a an
example of a broader question for
twitter which is if you uh
if you get invited to something where
there are no rules where there is total
freedom forever everybody do you
actually want to go to that party or are
you going to decide to stay home and
that's a question for twitter users some
twitter users might love the idea
there's going to be absolutely no
moderation and no rules at all others
might not want to be anywhere near that
am i am i crazy matt no no you're right
and what what happens to the advertising
i mean if there's no moderation or
little moderation do the advertisers
stay away what does that do to the
business prospects for twitter itself
and that's very much an open debate
so stelter is completely wrong in his
conclusion and in his premise both even
if his premise were right his conclusion
would still be wrong
well if elon musk gets rid of all the
speech regulations on twitter are people
even going to want to be there yeah they
will
he's really he's saying why would the
libs stay on twitter they're going to
stay on twitter for the same reason
conservatives are going to stay on
twitter when the when the twitter
leadership was going after conservatives
they're going to do it because that's
the public square
and twitter gained a critical mass
and now it plays a huge role in the
public square and so conservatives are
going to stay on it even when they go
after us even when they kick off trump
even when they kick off the babylon b
we're going to stay on it because that's
where it is that's where people talk
i wish that were not the case if that
were the case if that were not the case
elon musk wouldn't have had to go in and
buy it but that's why the conservatives
stayed on why are the libs going to stay
on the same reason
they can
where are they going to go they're going
to go to parlor
they're going to go to gab
they're going to go to truth social
they're going to go to the conservative
option no obviously no at least there
was an argument for conservatives to go
there
they're not going to go there
go to the liberal twitter that was
twitter until we until we took it away
from you
so that's why but but furthermore the
premise is wrong because
elon musk is not getting rid of all the
regulations
in fact elon musk said when he bought it
he said i'm going to add more
regulations i'm going to require some
verification so that you are who you say
or i'm going to get rid of the stupid
bots
he's going to take away certain
regulations too
he's going to free up speech he says
he's going to let conservatives talk
more he's not going to ban conservatives
for saying innocuous things
but
it's not really a debate between total
free speech and total censorship
i what's funny now is that the the left
through the voice of brian stelter
is taking the side against free speech
and for censorship in the 1960s they did
the opposite but it was always a false
debate this is the point of my book
speechless that's never the way it
really is the real question is what are
the standards what are you allowed to
say what are the customs what are the
mores what are the rules what are the
limits the libs had completely pushed it
in their direction so you weren't
allowed to question fouchy you weren't
allowed to say that boys aren't girls
you weren't allowed to say perfectly
ordinary things but you were allowed to
dox conservatives you were allowed to
threaten conservatives you were allowed
to do all sorts of terrible things and
now
now that conservatives maybe have a
little more control over twitter we're
going to move it back in the other
direction now when you want to
communicate directly with your customers
i would strongly recommend you check out
constant contact right now go to
constantcontact.com i have been using
constant contact since i was about 19
years old my first political campaign i
ever worked on we used constant contact
it is an amazing amazing tool i've
worked with it in different companies
and non-profits that i've worked with
it's just a phenomenal digital marketing
platform that helps small businesses and
non-profits of all sizes build grow and
succeed they've got email marketing
contact management industry-leading list
growth tools social media ads and more
constant contact help small businesses
connect with customers find new
customers and sell online all from one
easy to use platform they've been
trusted by millions of businesses to
help improve their marketing more
importantly they've been trusted by me
okay with a 97 deliverability rate you
can rest assured that your customers and
potential customers are getting the
right message at the right time
super easy interface easy to use contact
management it's just tremendous they've
got powerful automation tools to start
your free digital marketing trial today
go to constantcontact.com
yesterday was a really good day for elon
musk just
in general
yesterday
elon musk
not only took over twitter he also
signed his first deal with an airplane
to provide free wi-fi through his
company's spacex
because this guy is just doing whatever
he wants he's building cars he's sending
out rocket ships he's building global
internet he's owning twitter so
elon musk struck a deal with hawaiian
airlines
hawaiian airlines
obviously is flying over the pacific and
they've always had this issue with wi-fi
it's hard to get wi-fi when you're
flying over the middle of nowhere in the
pacific
so hawaiian has not offered wi-fi
that you could pay for or that you don't
pay for
elon goes in with his starlink system
which was providing some internet in
ukraine it can provide internet by
satellite and he said okay i'm going to
offer it for free to hawaii so that
there are
two aspects here one it's going to give
him a lot of control over internet
period
but two it's going to pressure other
companies to give free wi-fi on the
internet right now
you can go on on the most expensive
airline in america you can buy a first
class ticket you can spend you can spend
a thousand dollars or more on an
airplane ticket
and they still expect you to pay 30
bucks for the internet and that's kind
of annoying people don't like to do so
elon musk is pressuring the airlines now
maybe potentially transforming the way
that people communicate when they're up
in the air the way that we travel
and solving a problem for hawaiian
airlines and for other airlines that are
flying over the pacific where it's much
harder to provide internet
all of which brings me back to my first
point yes it's hilarious that the libs
are crying over this it's really really
funny yes it's really great that
conservatives are not nearly as censored
already you're seeing the shift i mean
i'm seeing this in real time right now
on my twitter account
but
the fact that he that elon musk can do
these things
is itself delightful
because it shows that the conservative
understanding of history the
conservative view of history that
individual moments really do matter
individual men really do matter
individual
twists of history actually do matter and
it's not all just some
totally discoverable scientistic
deterministic system
that the left wants us to believe that
is a wonderful delightful thing
i uh i don't want to say that i was
predicting what was going to happen with
the the
whole twitter saga
but you know sometimes i put on my
nostradamus hat
sometimes i take out my crystal ball and
i
sometimes i have to say i told you so
and the way that i was predicting just
this all happened so quickly i was just
maybe a few days ahead of where some of
the conversation was the one of the
reasons i was doing that whether it was
elon musk turning down the board seat
taking a tri admit potentially making a
tender offer to the shareholders
the one of the ways i could do that is
because elon musk was sending out these
really cryptic tweets and people were
debating what are the cryptic tweets
yesterday elon musk tweeted out
and be my love in the rain
now most people
thought okay he's just a weirdo he's
just tweeting out some random line i
don't know what that is maybe it's from
a song i don't know
i happen to be a fan of the american
poet robert frost
so
it was quickly clear to me that he was
referencing a robert frost poem the poem
is a line storm song
and so i went back i didn't really
remember all the lines of the poem i
looked back at this poem and one of the
lines
was quote
the birds have less to say for
themselves in the wood world's torn
despair
then now these numberless years the
elves although they are no less there
people told me michael studying
english and american poetry that's not
going to get you anywhere there's no
practical application well joke's on you
folks because the fact that i know a
little bit about poetry actually allowed
me to interpret where elon musk was
going with all of this the fact that
he's referencing the birds during this
whole saga about twitter does not seem
to me a coincidence the poem aligns a
line storm song
is about a destructive force
a sort of unpredicted and destructive
force violent force that comes in and
renews
the woods and renews the whole world
a chaotic forest may be like this
eccentric billionaire who comes in and
reorders the public square
the birds have less to say for
themselves that's right twitter had much
less to say for themselves it seems to
me to be signaling this is going to go
through i am buying this thing
and and this this comparison here
between the birds right the twitter
people
who are just going about their
technocratic lives and we've got
everything and we're in control of all
the speech and then here come those
elves those little those little magical
mystical forces that we sometimes deny
exist and we forget that that that
mystique around the way that the world
operates we forget that sometimes those
guys come in there and they just mess
things up and they turn things around
that i don't think i'm reading too
deeply into it because that's exactly
what played out previously musk had
tweeted out blank is the knight
blank is then some people are saying is
it lonely is the night is it this i knew
he was referring to
tender is the night which is the name of
an f scott fitzgerald novel and actually
the title of that f scott fitzgerald
novel comes from a poem by john keats
the poem is owed to a nightingale and
the line in that poem is and mid-may's
eldest child the coming musk rose full
of dewy wine the murmurous haunt of
flies on summer reeves is it a
coincidence that the poem that he's
referencing has the word musk right in
it a sort of unusual word is in it i
don't think so i don't think that i've i
i don't think that i'm the uh sort of
romantic you know uh nose in the air uh
version of alex jones here you know
putting on my tinfoil hat trying to read
tea leaves i think what this is telling
or what this is showing rather
is that elon musk
is a very sophisticated thinker
this is a guy who doesn't do things by
accident he just for one how many how
many
business tycoons do you know
who are familiar with poetry not very
many usually they're the kind of
humanities people usually there are the
kind of artistic types and then there
are the business types who are only
interested in commerce
or technology or engineering
and yet here's elon musk
i think pretty clearly referencing
fitzgerald and keats but certainly
without question he's referencing the
robert frost poem he actually knows
something about this and it's even
funnier because he's south african he's
not even he's not even american now he's
an african-american because he's become
american but that's a story for another
time
all of this to say
not that
it's particularly important that people
could
could decipher exactly what poems the
guy was referencing all of this to say
this guy is operating on a much higher
level
than most people in public life
this guy
the joke about washington dc the joke
about congress is that the average iq is
something like 85 right that our our
representatives in dc are very often
much stupider than the average american
they don't know very much they're just
kind of glad handing windbags
a lot of people in business are that way
too actually they just they just are all
about commerce they're just all about
dollars and cents elon musk is not just
about congress
when elon musk says my decision to buy
twitter is not purely economic
i think he's being honest i think he's
telling the truth this guy has higher
ambitions this guy is going to be a line
storm song that this guy's going to be a
line storm where we're in the song right
now i guess who is going to come in and
just out of nowhere mess things up and
turn things around
and shake up the
dreary apparently deterministic course
of history and decay and he's going to
come in and say no
no we're not going to do that so this is
really really great stuff not just
because we can tweet
about how dr fauci is a liar and how men
aren't women and how ivermectin's a
wonder drug and not just because we can
do that that's all fun too but because
of what it says about history because of
what it says about the way that we can
affect the the course of of political
development
so of course you know what's going to
happen
the libs are going to try to take this
guy out they're already doing it
there was a story and i think there's a
variety yesterday one of the trade
publications in hollywood that fx and
the new york times
have just announced an elon musk expose
that right on time
right on time i get they probably had to
speed it up a little bit
because
the musk twitter takeover sort of came
out of nowhere and then occurred really
quickly
it occurred within just a matter of
weeks and so now they've got their
expose and the expose is going to focus
on his car company tesla
and how the self-driving car experiments
have resulted in in deaths and so
they're going to focus on that and
they're going to try to basically paint
him as a sociopathic
killer probably a serial killer i don't
know they're gonna they're gonna accuse
him all sorts of things
which is
which is uh fine by me
to me it makes me more likely to to
defend the elon musk i don't i don't
know the man i don't know exactly what
he believes the things that i've heard
that he believes make me confident that
he's basically got his head screwed on
straight the fact for instance that he
rejects the overpopulation narrative
this preposterous liberal narrative that
goes back actually centuries but has
been really popular for the last 50
years the fact that elon says actually
the world is underpopulated the fact
that he seems to be pro-human the fact
that he seems to be pro-american
tradition of free speech the
these are all good signs
but the
the thing that makes me most likely to
support this guy is the fact that the
new york times and fx and the hollywood
liberal establishment
is trying to take him out the fact that
blackrock and state street were were
trying to squeeze him out that the
twitter board was trying to keep him out
to me that's the best argument when i'm
when i'm trying to figure out who my
political allies are i look at what my
political opponents are doing who their
most
vociferously opposing and then i think
huh that person must have something
right now if you have not heard
speaking of important voices
my friend matt walsh is a very important
voice in the transgender movement he is
the author of the best-selling
children's lgbtq plus book johnny the
walrus if you haven't picked up a copy
of his best-selling children's book you
should do so immediately
it sold out in less than 24 hours when
it was released but don't worry
it's back in stock right now it will
sell out again so pick up your copy of
johnny the walrus today at
johnnythewalrus.com or on amazon we'll
be right back with a lot more
not only is the new york times going
after elon musk not only is fx hollywood
going after elon musk the white house is
going after him too
jenn saki white house press secretary
was asked yesterday about the twitter
takeover
and she seemed to
to
suggest that the white house is going to
be taking a stronger hand in regulating
social media now
does the white house have any concern
that this new agreement might have
president trump back on the platform
well i'm not going to comment on a
specific transaction uh what i can tell
you as a general matter no matter who
owns or runs
twitter the president has long been
concerned about the power of large
social media platforms uh what they have
that power they have over our everyday
lives has long argued that tech
platforms must be held accountable for
the harms they cause he has been a
strong supporter of fundamental reforms
to achieve that goal including reforms
to section 230 enacting anti-trust
reforms requiring more transparency and
more and he's encouraged uh that there's
bipartisan interest in congress uh in
terms of what hypothetical policies
might happen i'm just not going to speak
to that at this point in time
gensake said one word there that tells
you the whole game
everyone thinks this is about free
speech
including many if not most conservatives
and it's not it's just not
this is about that one word that jensaki
said
power
it's about power
it's about
who is setting the rules who has the
right to set the rules who is enforcing
the rules
notice gensake says the president's
concerned about the harm that social
media causes
what are we talking about the harm that
it causes are we talking about the harm
to kids developing brains that's
actually a real that's a real problem
when kids are just spending 52 minutes
on average on tick tock a day swiping
and getting their brains melted by weird
chinese propaganda yeah that's that's a
concern that's not what they're talking
about they talking about the threats to
the public square the harm caused to
democracy
when you kick half the country offer you
or at least you suppress what half the
country is allowed to say you kick the
dually elected sitting president off
just because he's a conservative
no i don't think i don't think biden's
talking about that
he's talking about the harm
of misinformation
the harm of questioning dr fauci the
harm of raising questions about the 2020
election
the harm of
questioning the democrat narrative the
harm of saying that boys aren't really
girls
that's what he's talking about he's what
what jen saki is saying is
we're going to go in
and and fight elon musk and take this
away from him
and therefore take away from you
conservatives the strongest voice you've
had in social media in a long time
it's about power it's not about
free speech it's about who sets the
standards who holds the power
elon musk
is not
maybe he'll free up speech a little bit
or maybe he'll just free it up in
certain places and restrict it more in
other places like for instance anonymous
accounts that's probably more likely
what's going to happen maybe he'll just
shift the way that speech is done but
what he certainly did was shift the
balance of power and the white house
does not like that very much that's what
all these battles are about moving on
from social media because it's not only
about social media this is what the
education fight's about
the education fight is not about free
speech
if the education fight were about free
speech in florida right now
conservatives would be against free
speech
and liberals would be for free speech
because we're saying we need to restrict
the number of books you can teach in the
classroom we're trying to restrict the
number of words that you can say in the
classroom we're trying to restrict the
number of conversations that
kindergarten teachers could have
that's a good thing
teachers should not be allowed to say
whatever they want in the classroom
there's that has no place in the
american free speech tradition it's
completely incoherent it has nothing to
do with what education is
in the 1960s
conservatives were on were against free
speech in the sense that they were
against
relaxing obscenity standards
they were against relaxing
other norms and customs and standards in
our speech and behavior it was the
liberals who were pushing forward and
they used free speech as an instrument
to do that
but it was never genuine
the very people who pushed the free
speech movement at berkeley then became
the most
pro-censorship people in the country
because it's it's never about that sort
of thing okay and so i think we've we've
got to ditch that kind of talk i don't
think that kind of talk is particularly
helpful and we need to recognize that
what we're talking about here is a
little more about the substance it's a
little less about the abstraction and
it's a little bit more about the
substance is a kindergarten teacher
trying to trans a five-year-old well
then that teacher's out see ya sayonara
sucker bye
but but my free speech right to talk
about how little kids should mutilate
their bodies and take no you don't have
that right if that's what free speech is
i'm against that's not really what free
speech is but if that's what it is then
never mind see you bye
this is a popular message
not just among old fuddy-duddies by the
way
it's actually especially a popular
message among young people there's a new
poll it's just out it's a national poll
from the harvard kennedy school so it's
not exactly a right-wing institution
that shows that
18 to 29 year olds in particular agree
with the statement
parents should have more control over
their children's education than they do
now
46 agree with that statement only 23
percent disagree with that statement
so it's not just that the the young
people are for whatever you want to
teach in the schools man and free speech
man and it's the old fuddy duddies who
are saying actually it's
it's disproportionately the young people
who realize who have children right now
who have kids in these schools who
realize no i don't want you teaching my
kid critical race theory you weirdo i
don't want you telling little johnny
he's really little jane no we need more
controls in schools over what kids can
say or at least different controls right
now if a teacher teaches the bible in a
classroom the teacher is certainly going
to be fired it might be i don't know
might be charged with some sort of crime
or something
they'll have violated the law those
teachers
meanwhile if a teacher teaches the
gender unicorn or the gender-bred man or
any weird perverted sexual stuff in
class the teacher will be applauded the
teacher will be encouraged by the biden
administration
so it's not about it's not even about
more or less speech it's just about what
are you teaching what is the substance
here daily wire had previously reported
that the the kovid 19 lockdowns probably
had something to do with this shift in
attitudes because during covid19
really i don't even want to say during
covet 19 because there was covid19
there's the virus which is sort of
whatever i think most people out there
have had it by now
and then there there were the lockdowns
and i think they were basically separate
phenomena
the covet 19 virus was the excuse for
the lockdowns but i don't think that the
politics of the lockdowns had very much
to do with the virus
so in any case you've got two years of
lockdowns and during which time
virtually every student is being
homeschooled to some degree in as much
as they're at least sitting on home they
might be on a computer or an ipad but
they're still at home
doing distance learning and a lot of
kids were just taken out of the schools
and taught by their parents so you had
you had homeschooling rates grow from
5.4 percent
in march of 2020 to 11
in just in september of 2020 so that's a
six month period
by the summer of 2021
5 million american children were
receiving their education at home which
is a huge number
and all of a sudden these parents get a
taste of that
and they say oh hold on my kid doesn't
need to just be indoctrinated for eight
hours a day into critical race theory or
into weird sex theories or
into just leftist politics generally oh
that doesn't that's not a requirement we
actually can i can have some say over
this i like that that's pretty good
not just the radical right-wing
republicans if it were only the radical
extreme right-wing republicans those
numbers wouldn't be possible that's a
huge
upswing what are kids being taught in
school let's leave the elementary
schools for a second let's go all the
way up to college
there's a school in in utah
westminster college salt lake city utah
they are right now offering a course on
hardcore pornography
this is a private college not state
sponsored but it's a private college
offering a course on hardcore porn this
is gender 3000. so already you know the
course is in a gender studies department
which means it should be abolished
because gender studies and all of these
sort of critical studies that cropped up
in recent decades to give stupid
students something that they can study
because they weren't able to keep up in
the real
in the real academic disciplines so you
say okay we're going to do
gender and ethnicity and migration
studies and it's just it's just an
education in leftism and so as long as
you say the right political slogans you
can get a good grade and you can
graduate it was a it was a way to give
the the left an even stronger foothold
in education so the minute you see
gender studies you think okay
never mind this should get get rid of
this as long as we're fixing standards
here just abolish this whole department
turn it into a library or something in
any case the gender 3 studies course
is called porn and here's the
description hardcore pornography is as
american as apple pie and more popular
than sunday night football our approach
to this billion dollar industry is as
both a cultural phenomenon that reflects
and reinforces sexual inequalities but
holds the potential to challenge sexual
and gender norms and as an art form that
requires serious contemplation we will
watch pornographic films together and
discuss the sexualization of race class
and gender as an experimental radical
art form this is a very bad idea this is
very harmful to students education
should not be permitted at any college
or university in the country
this is extremely obscene this appeals
primarily to the prairie interest and it
is not protected by free speech in in
the american tradition this class would
have no free speech protection
no first amendment protection
why
i it's not because
pornography is not a worthwhile
phenomenon to discuss it is it's a it's
a huge problem in america it's a major
political problem we don't really talk
about it enough
it's it's destroying the lives of
especially a lot of young men how many
times every week i get letters into my
mailbag lots of letters into my mailbag
saying i've been hooked on porn since i
was 10 it's ruined my life how do we fix
it so i i think the conversation is
really important to have i think it's
really important to study how
pornography was mainstreamed into
america how legal prohibitions against
it were overturned that's a really
interesting conversation
but that's not what this class does this
class involves sitting down
with boys and girls
and the teacher
watching this stuff
well that's very different
it'd be like taking a class on crystal
meth
and cocaine
and hardcore narcotics
you could take a class on that in
chemistry for instance and talk about
these drugs and what they do and
their effects and and you can even have
a policy discussion on whether or not
they should be legal or regulated that
class would be perfectly fine but the
minute that the class says okay and as
part of your final exam you're all going
to do a bunch of crystal and tell me how
it feels you're all going to blow a
bunch of lines of coke smoke a pipe of
crack and tell me how it feels
that's a very different thing and that's
what this porn class is doing because
the way that you use a
crack cocaine is by smoking it the way
that you use heroin is by injecting it
the way that you use pornography is by
watching it the very act of watching
pornography is what destroys that sort
of academic environment because when you
watch porn it's the same reason that you
shouldn't be doing
these kind of hardcore drugs when you
watch pornography you are not appealing
to your rational
faculties you're not appealing to your
intellect you actually you're not
appealing to your irrational will you're
losing control of that because you're
appealing to the appetite
if you if you watch a lot of porn if you
do a lot of drugs if you drink too much
if you
do things
that are in the indulgence of your vices
you're going to lose your higher will
it's going to you're going to weaken
your rational faculties and that's not a
very good thing that's unfortunately
that's what our society has become
i know that we always talk about 1984 by
george orwell as though that were the
description of the society we're living
in there's censorship there's an
increasingly totalitarian form of
government yeah sure
actually
the way that the establishment controls
the american people is much more like
brave new world by aldous huxley than
1984 by george orwell
huxley who was orwell's french teacher i
believe actually wrote a letter to him
to this effect and said you know george
it's a good book that you wrote but my
version of it is more accurate as to how
how political elites actually gain power
they don't do it by just smacking you
with a stick they don't do it by beating
you into submission they usually do it
by appealing to your desires by
appealing to your appetites and your
lusts they do it by by promoting drugs
by promoting promiscuous sex by
destroying the family by which which is
more when you look at those two visions
of a dystopian society which seems more
correct the absolute rigid transparent
party program that has all of these very
strict rules that you've got to follow
or
or a society of licentiousness and
hedonism that tells you if it feels good
do it obviously it's the latter that's
the way the society is decaying and
that's what that's not only is that a
function of the the really decayed
aspects of of popular culture that's now
what's literally being taught in in
universities the purpose of which is to
do the opposite the purpose of which is
to give you a liberal education and
teach you how to make sense of your
freedom
that's what's going on that's going on
in the universities
you're getting a similar perhaps a light
little watered down version in the high
schools
in the middle schools and despite what
the libs tell you you are getting this
kind of weird stuff
in the elementary schools
thanks again to libs of tick tock
one of my favorite twitter accounts
which i suspect is going to get even
more of a boost now that now that the uh
left is not suppressing conservatives
accounts quite as much
libs of tick tock posted a video
of a teacher playing a slideshow about
how he is going to indoctrinate kids
into transgenderism it opens up it says
just this quote stop brainwashing our
children in the classroom with the lgbt
agenda the teacher kind of looks and
smiles and laughs
says ms beeman is now mix beamon
you know me as ms beeman i'm still your
teacher but now i'm mixed beam because
i'm non-gendered now and i'll go by he
and they and i'm transgender and
non-binary and i'm the same me but we're
gonna work together so that you can
recognize that i'm not just a boy or a
girl what's transgender what's
non-binary it's where you look like one
thing but you're actually a different
sex on the inside and that's why i've
got to be mix now mx rather than mr or
ms or mrs or miss really
because that's what transgenderism says
and transgenderism is true
that's just i i did give the quick
version because it's tick-tock so
they're moving very quickly
but that's what a teacher is teaching
five-year-olds i actually i don't know
what
what level of student this teacher is
teaching whether it's a five-year-old or
whether it's an 18 year old for that
matter
it's just not true
the teacher is saying that
transgenderism is real that you can
really secretly be the opposite sex that
you should call people by this made-up
prefix mix
and that
she is now really a he or they and and
that's not true
her name is they because they are legion
or something no that's none of that is
true and the teacher should be fired or
put into counseling i mean the teacher
should be probably placed on leave told
to go see a psychiatrist psychologist
unfortunately these days the
psychologist will just affirm this woman
in her delusions and but if the
psychologist somehow could convince the
woman that she really is a woman and she
realizes that she was deluded before
then maybe she could come back and teach
the kids but if she if she's not going
to be convinced of reality and she's
going to insist on peddling destructive
falsehoods in the classroom then you got
to fire her
because she's harming kids education and
she has no right to do that
it's not an act of cruelty to do that
it's it's actually an act of compassion
to the students and compassion to her
because the further down this rabbit
hole of fantasy she gets the worse off
she's going to be people don't flourish
when they are totally untethered from
reality
got to
get a little tougher because sometimes
getting tougher is more loving that's
that's what we call tough love
speaking of the mistreatment of kids now
that
the american people are so done with
kovid and they're so done with the
ridiculous public health measures that
were based on lots of lies and
errors and deception
now that they're really really done
there's this last gasp this desperate
final push to keep the country locked
down on msnbc you've got some quacks
showing up saying that the new the new
uh fad the new fashion
is of course you need to keep wearing
your mask even though this the court
said you no longer have to uh yes you
absolutely have to social distance and
take your 7000th vaccine and you know do
all the sorts of things that dr fauci
wants you to do but even for your kids
you're really really little kids who are
too young to take the vaccine and who
are too young to wear a mask well you
need to you basically need to put them
in a space helmet
parents of young kids less than six
months of age if they've been breastfed
there is something they will have some
degree of protective antibodies my
wife's a pediatrician you know we chat
about this at the dinner table you if
you have something if you have a
different way to get your own
destination and you want to travel with
your child that's less than six months
of age
try the car if you can
if not
if you can avoid traveling for those
first six months ideal in an airplane
cabin moving forward this is something
that some pediatricians are recommending
for six months of asian above katie the
bucket hat with the face shield i
personally have not purchased this but
it might help with some droplet
protection just something that we can do
here to protect our kiddos while we're
where these are also
clearance for that that group
they're also very cute on kiddos yeah
they're really really cute a bucket hat
with a face shield so you've got to
they want you to put on your
four-month-old baby they want you to put
the little hat maybe you can put it on
if the baby goes in the sun like a
little bonnet with just a giant plastic
cone around it a little face shield
for the for the baby
for the little baby who's scared of his
own shadow who just wants to snuggle up
next to mommy you've got to put him in a
basically a hazmat suit
to protect against the virus that
statistically poses an extremely low
risk to children
two years after well over two years
after six two weeks to slow the spread
rather
i'm not going to do that i don't think
you're going to do that i don't think
anyone should take the that
all that seriously
this is how they operate i don't mention
it because this sheds any light on
coronavirus or the lockdown it sheds
light on politics they are so
desperate to hold on to this power
why did they turn down that good offer
from elon musk that offered a premium on
twitter because the power is worth more
to them than the money
and the power is worth money really in
the long run
why are they holding on to the
coronavirus two years after two weeks to
slow the spread after we know that the
the projections about death counts were
just completely bogus after they've even
had to revise down the total death
counts by
three quarters what was it 72 000 people
or something just a few months ago and
probably it will be even more than that
in the end why why why
because the power is worth a whole lot
to them
speaking of
the poor treatment of children i do have
to get to this this point
uh there's a horrible decision that was
just made today by a criminal court
texas's highest criminal court just
halted the execution of a woman who
tortured and killed her two-year-old
daughter
this woman melissa lucille she was she's
one of the people who
kim kardashian and other
very ignorant left-wing political
activists have been
trying to get off the hook this woman
had 14 i think it was
14 total kids might have been 14 kids
plus this little girl
uh she
tortured and killed this little girl the
little girl was found
initially this mother said that the way
the little daughter died was by because
she fell down the stairs it's the oldest
excuse in the history of domestic
violence uh the experts later found no
she was
killed by blunt force trauma the mother
confessed to killing her daughter there
were bite marks on this woman hair had
been pulled out she had a broken arm for
weeks before she was ultimately killed
just horrific horrific torture the woman
certainly needs to face her punishment
i hope she repents i hope she turn turns
her life around hanging concentrates the
mind but what this tells you what this
decision tells you is one this society
does not care about kids at all we don't
we're conducting creepy medical
experiments on kids that are going to
destroy their bodies potentially give
them
bone diseases
like the puberty blockers for instance
that are going to make them infertile
that are going to sterilize them all
because of our weird ideological fads to
make delusional adults feel better about
their sexual dysfunctions and disorders
we're killing eight hundred thousand
babies a year in this country uh at
least for now hopefully we'll overturn
roe versus wade the one it tells you
society doesn't care about the kids and
and two it tells you that this society
is harshest to the innocent and most
lenient to the guilty that's a
disordered society it's a society where
the standards are upside down and we
need to go in there and exert our
political will and reorder them i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the men shapiro show twitter
accepts elon musk's offer to buy and we
examine all the leftist panic and all
the possibilities that's today on the
ben shapiro show give it a listen